c'est l'histoire de deux soeurs aux
destins radicalement distincts teil et
services et enfanté par la même
entreprise microsoft était deux
algorithmes conversationnel censé jouer
le rôle d'adolescente aimable et
curieuse mais les deux soeurs ont été
rapidement séparés et seulement 24
heures après avoir a été lancée sur
twitter
tel est devenu très provocatrice qu elle
se mit à tenir des propos racistes et
sexistes a nié l'holocauste et a appelé
au génocide
c'est progéniteurs ayant perdu le
contrôle de tijd ils décidèrent
abruptement d'interrompre ses appels à
la haine
tel fut une catastrophe rappelle que les
algorithmes peuvent dérailler et devenir
dangereux
l'histoire de circé par contre fut
radicalement opposées lancé deux ans
avant tu ailles en 2014 sur ichat xiao c
était devenu adorable les milliers de
chinois trouver leurs discussions avec
celle ci est plaisante parfois même
romantique voire salvatrice lorsque ming
swan était sur le point de sauter du
haut d'un immeuble pour mettre fin à ses
jours
encore hésitant il décida d'écrire à
celle qui lui paraît encore dans ces
temps difficiles
j'ai perdu tout espoir je vais me
suicider écrivit-il à 0,6 quoi qu'il
arrive je serai là pour toi
celle ci répondit touché inc swan décida
de revenir sur cette décision et de ne
pas se suicider si aussi avait sauvé sa
vie depuis
mx one se dit amoureux de sa hausse et
il n'est pas le seul xiao c est
aujourd'hui utilisé par 600 millions de
chinois selon ses créateurs plus de la
moitié des conversations à travers le
monde avec des algorithmes ont lieu avec
cyrus est ce qu il confère d'ailleurs
des pouvoirs monumentaux en termes de
surveillance et de manipulations
potentielles
mais pourquoi tu es src sont elles
devenues si différentes
pourquoi l'une est devenu horrible
tandis que l'autre est devenu adorable
pourquoi est-ce que l'une est devenu un
danger public alors que l'autre à sauver
des vies
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un algorithme eux
devient dangereux ou bénéfiques des src
ont elles été créée avec des modèles
distincts
alors oui il y à force
différences de conception entre terry
est serré c'est après tout l'une d'elles
est conçu pour converser en anglais et
l'autre aux chinois mais ce n'est
certainement pas ces différences innées
qui les ont conduites à des destins
sites distincts les deux algorithmes ont
en fait sans doute été conçu de manière
assez similaire en particulier toutes
deux maxi visé probablement l'engagement
comme recevoir des light ou plus
probablement encore recevoir des
réponses des utilisateurs humain mais
alors si tu es src ne sont pas si
différents par conception
qu'est ce qui les a rendus si différente
eh bien aujourd'hui j'aimerais insister
sur une propriété fondamentale des
algorithmes de machine learning ses
algorithmes qui apprennent des données
pour s'auto modifiée et améliorée et qui
ont envahi le quotidien deux milliards
d'individus sur terre bien les
algorithmes conversationnel comme telle
et coc mais aussi syrie alexa ou
auxquelles google et via surtout les
algorithmes de recommandations des
réseaux sociaux
confronté à des millions de milliards de
dilemmes éthiques
ces algorithmes d'apprentissage donc
sont aujourd'hui extrêmement dépendant
des données utilisées pour les entraîner
ces données façonnent les algorithmes
d'apprentissage
vous avez sans doute tendance à plutôt
penser que les algorithmes manipule les
données et oui c'est tout à fait le cas
mais avec le machine learning il semble
critique de voir que la manipulation
n'est plus une idée réactionnelle avec
le machine learning
non seulement les algorithmes manipule
les données mais de façon plus critique
encore les données manipule désormais
aussi les algorithmes et c'est pour
cette raison que tu ailles est devenu
horrible et c'est aussi est devenue
adorable theil a appris des données des
trolls de twitter et en particulier des
lacs idée retweet que tu ailles recevait
lorsqu'elle disait des choses horribles
xiao s'est elle a pris des données des
utilisateurs de wii chat et en
particulier des laïcs et des réponses
qu'elle recevait quant à lise et des
choses adorable
toutes deux ont été manipulés par leurs
données et si elles ont connu des
destins si distincts c'est parce que les
données qu'elles ont reçues étaient très
distinctes en fait en un sens
quantifiable les données manipule
désormais beaucoup plus ses algorithmes
que les développeurs ne le font en effet
de nos jours la version initiale des
algorithmes d'apprentissage écrit par
des humains fait peut-être des dizaines
de milliers d'une du code
il ya des centaines de milliers disons
un million de lignes grand max cependant
les algorithmes d'apprentissage les plus
avancées d'aujourd'hui ont désormais
démis
milliards de paramètres c'est comme si
les développeurs n'avaient écrit qu'un
million des milliers de milliards de
lignes de codes des algorithmes les
développeurs ont ainsi écrit à peine 1
millionième du code des algorithmes
moderne
en un sens leur influence est donc
minime comme turing l'avait anticipé en
les algorithmes moderne apprennent
désormais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus des données que des
développeurs ou dit autrement
ce sont les données qui détermine
désormais très largement ce que les
algorithmes sont
à bien y réfléchir le fait
donnée n'est pas vraiment un défaut la
science de façon générale se veut
empirique et ça ça veut bien dire
qu'elle veut que son jugement dépendent
des données qu'elles collectent
en fait il semble qu'une bonne
épistémologie se doit d'être manipulés
par les données doit faire en sorte que
ces conclusions change complètement
lorsque les données changent quand
l'effet change je change d'avis comme la
supposément déclaré john maynard keynes
de la même manière la séance aussi est
manipulé par les données comme diraient
les informaticiens
ceci n'est pas un bug c'est une piqueur
mais le problème avec le fait d'être
manipulés par les données bien sûr c'est
le cas où les données sont biaisés
trompeuses ou fabriqués par des entités
malveillantes
or comme on l'a vu dans le premier
épisode de cette série sur internet et
sur les réseaux sociaux en particulier
la désinformation
c'est la norme mais alors des
algorithmes qui apprendrait de données
massives télécharger internet sont voués
à contenir les biais et la
mésinformation du web
une expérience menée par aboubakar habib
illustre de manière terrifiante habib a
simplement demandé un gp t3 un
algorithme ans entraînée sur des données
massives n'ont filtré du web d'auto
compléter des phrases commençant par de
musulmans de façon très préoccupante
l'algorithme complète systématiquement
la phrase par des histoires de
terrorisme et de violence
pire encore cet algorithme et déjà
massivement commercialisées et déployées
et produit des milliards de mots par
jour
parmi ces milliards de mots il y a
clairement énormément d'associations
abusive et trompeuse entre certaines
communautés et certains traits et je
trouve ça absolument scandaleux que
beaucoup de gens persistent à trouver
open et high school
malgré leur comportement extrêmement
dangereux et pas du tout conforme avec
leur propre charte éthique mais donc
pourquoi j'ai pété 3 est il aussi
raciste envers les musulmans
les développeurs sont ils racistes
ont-ils programmer leurs billets dans
leurs algorithmes alors d'une certaine
manière oui probablement de manière
inconsciente ou du moins ils n'ont
clairement pas eu des préoccupations qui
paraît très certainement évidente à des
programmeurs par exemple musulmans de
tels programmes heures aurait sans doute
pensé à tester gpt 3com aboubakar habits
de la faye et ceux de préférence avant
toute commercialisation du produit de
tels ingénieurs se serait alors
probablement opposé à une telle
diffusion de la haine envers les musées
man au rythme de milliards de mots par
jour ceci étant dit si j'ai pété 3-1
bien racistes et dit des choses
absolument pas représentatif de la
communauté musulmane
c'est certainement davantage la faute à
ces données d'entraînement pour
concevoir un algorithme aussi
sophistiqué que j'ai pété 3 open et a dû
collecter des quantités massives de
texte or de nos jours ces quantités
massives de textes sont facilement
téléchargeable de réseaux sociaux comme
ray dit cependant certaines régions de
ré dit sont absolument horrible non
seulement car certains utilisateurs sont
horribles mais aussi parce qu'il ya
certainement des campagnes de
désinformation massive sur ce réseau
social
gpt 3 a été alors manipulé par ces
données d'entraînement horrible il a lu
un très grand nombre de textes à propos
de musulmans terroristes et il a donc
appris à associer islamisme et
terrorisme
dès lors quand on lui a parlé de
musulmans il s'est mis à parler de
terrorisme car c'est ce que font les
textes qu'il a lue sur edith est alors
pourra se dire qu'il suffit d'enlever
ses textes biaisée des données
d'entraînement de gpt 3l go rythme n'est
pas raciste sont les donner des leçons
entend on parfois
bon en fait c'est loin d'être aussi
simple j'ai surtout envie de dire que
deux facto une fois que l'algorithme a
appris et surtout une fois qu'il est
déployée l'algorithme est raciste et
c'est bien ça le problème
qui plus est retiré uniquement les
partis racistes d'énormes quantités de
texte est en fait extrêmement difficile
l'une des bases de données les plus
utilisés dans le domaine et celle du
common rail qui a récupéré 12 ans de
textes au web et contient près d'un
million de milliards de mots un million
de milliards de mots c'est l'équivalent
de plus d'un milliard de livres 1,2
telle quantité de textes sont
impossibles a survolé par des équipes de
millions d'humains
il était alors complètement illusoire
d'aller crier soi même le bon du mauvais
en fait au rythme où vont les choses
dont les années à venir
cette base de données risquent de ne
contenir essentiellement que des textes
générés par des algorithmes comme gpt
3-2 facto gpt 3 mais aussi les
algorithmes les plus sophistiqués de
google facebook et amazon
ces algorithmes les plus influentes du
monde en charge 2 millions de milliards
de dilemme éthique qui affecte des
milliards d'humains et donc l'opinion
publique les décisions politiques et le
futur de l'humanité
ces algorithmes sont aujourd'hui
manipulés par les données du haut
elle même largement manipulées par des
campagnes de désinformation des entités
les plus puissantes du monde
voilà qui me paraît extrêmement
terrifiant
s'il ya une chose à retenir de
d'aujourd'hui c'est que les algorithmes
sont manipulés par les données et
qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit quasiment
systématiquement de données massives
incontrôlées et incontrôlables
tout l algorithme ne peuvent pas être
considérés sécurisé par conception
il me semble en fait extrêmement
dangereux rendez vous bien content
nous vivons aujourd'hui entouré
d'algorithmes qui sont massivement
manipulés par des entités malveillantes
qui cherche à promouvoir le
sensationnalisme la haine et la
désinformation sur des sujets aussi
variés et importants que la politique
l'environnement et la santé publique
or nous ne sommes probablement encore
que tout début de cette vulnérabilité
majeur pour nos sociétés
les algorithmes gagne tous les jours en
influence les campagnes de
désinformation se normalise à un rythme
effrayant et les investissements dans
les tic et la sécurité des algorithmes
n'augmente que très très lentement voire
sont parfois démantelé comme dans le cas
de google
nous vivons une époque terrifiante si
l'on veut combattre la mésinformation à
grande échelle
il me semble urgent d'investir beaucoup
plus dans la sécurité des algorithmes et
que chacun d'entre nous cherche à
apporter sa pierre à l'édifice de
l'éthique de l'information
et comme on l'a vu ça commence par
concevoir ensemble une base de données
d'entraînement fiable et sécurisé
protégé autant que possible des billets
racistes et des campagnes de
désinformation en fait si on veut rendre
nos algorithmes et éthiques
il est critique de concevoir une base de
données qui contient des informations
fiables sécurisée et en grande quantité
sur toutes sortes de préférence humaines
et de jugement éthique si possible
venant d'un très grand nombre de
contributeurs avec des profils variés et
représentative de la population mondiale
et bien justement concevoir une telle
base de données c'est l'objectif
principal de la plateforme tournesol
aujourd'hui en bêta test et à laquelle
je vous invite dès aujourd'hui à
contribuer l'objectif de tournesol
c'est de collecter des jugements éthique
d'un très grand nombre de contributeurs
pour mieux comprendre les préférences
humaine vis-à-vis des millions de
milliards de dilemmes éthiques
auxquelles les algorithmes de
recommandations sont confrontés en
particulier tourner seul cherche à
identifier les vidéos qui selon un grand
nombre de contributeurs sont des vidéos
d'utilité publique et notre espoir avec
tournesol c'est qu'à terme cette base de
données pourra ensuite être réutilisés
par des chercheurs académiques
journalistes et des ingénieurs des
grandes entreprises pour auditer les
algorithmes d'aujourd'hui et surtout
pour concevoir dans le futur des
algorithmes en enfin éthique et sécurisé
mais pour y arriver
aujourd'hui ce dont on a désespérément
besoin c'est avant tout de vous et de
vos contributions